the president was interviewed by fox
news host chris
wallace in an interview that aired
yesterday and
it is unlike anything that i've ever
seen and i want to spend some time today
looking at it with you and it's really
the stuff of history i mean this is an
interview that needs to be analyzed
really like that infamous as a pruder
film because the english language
is stretched to its limit to even
explain and describe what took place
during this interview donald trump at
one point stopped the interview to try
to get documents
proving joe biden wants to abolish the
police
which joe biden doesn't want to do and
donald trump was
unable to prove with those documents he
tried to get
trump was sweating so badly that at one
point it looked like
flop sweat he was glistening and
dripping with sweat throughout the
interview
trump referred to world wars 1 and 2 as
beautiful
beautiful trump challenged joe biden
to a cognitive test and accused the
interviewer chris wallace
of being unable to answer some of the
test questions
on the cognitive test and that's like
only the half of it
trump has insulted people in interviews
but he was unhinged
here trump has said dumb and wrong
things
in interviews but trump seemed impaired
here so let's get right out into it uh
sit down
join me in this adventure which is
really a horror show
the country can never allow something
like this to happen
again it is historic in its level of
insanity
i'm going to start with arguably one of
the most deranged moments of the entire
thing
which is that chris wallace shows trump
a poll
about trump versus biden on mental
soundness which we'll talk about later
more people in the poll it's a fox news
poll more people think joe biden is
mentally sound to be president
than the number who think trump is
mentally sound and donald trump starts
saying not only can he do better than
biden on a cognitive test
it gets really ugly and he actually says
to chris wallace
i would do better than you you would
struggle to answer some of the questions
on the cognitive test completely and
utterly unhinged
people who is more competent who's got
whose mind
is sounder biden beats you in that well
i'll tell you what
uh let's take a test let's take a test
right now
let's go down joe and i will take a test
let him take the same test
that i took incidentally i took the test
too when i heard that you passed it yeah
how did you do it
well it's not the hardest test no but it
has a picture and it's the left side and
it's an element no no
you see that's all misrepresentation
that's what it was on the web it's all
misrepresentation
because yes the first few questions are
easy but i'll bet you couldn't even
answer the last five questions i bet you
couldn't they get very hard the last
five well one of them was count back
from 100 by seven
and let me tell you if you couldn't
answer
you couldn't answer all right what's the
question many of the questions i'd get
you the test i'd like to give it
but i guarantee you that joe biden could
not answer those questions
okay and i answered all 35 questions
correctly
we're clearly desensitized by more than
three years
of this because the president of the
united states told
the interviewer that the interviewer
would be unable to do as well on a
cognitive test meant to screen out
dementia
than the way trump answered the
questions and it's like just a blip
honestly there were equally crazy things
in this interview never mind other
things that happened this weekend
there are some real questions here
though that that i should mention
what test is trump talking about because
trump talks about the 35 questions the
montreal cognitive assessment
which is as far as we know what trump
took and it was certainly what chris
wallace was referring to it doesn't have
35 questions
it's based out of 30 points but we don't
actually know what test trump is
referring to
trump not may not even remember the test
itself and as far as we knew trump took
that test a year or two ago
but trump recently said i just took it
when was that and where we're not aware
of trump being administered that or any
other cognitive test
recently this was maybe the most
mind-numbingly
bizarre moment of the interview then we
get on to
the biden attacks here trump says biden
wants to defund the police
joe biden doesn't want to defund or
abolish the police
and in fact there's people on the left
who are mad at joe biden because he
doesn't want to defund or abolish the
police
and chris wallace calls trump on it
trump stops the interview
to try to get the proof that that's what
biden wants to do
of course it doesn't work that way
because biden doesn't want to abolish
the police take a look you've seen
deaths
up in new york deaths up in chicago
shootings
how do you explain it and what are you
going to do about it i explain it very
simply by saying that the democrat-run
cities they're
liberally run they're stupidly run
liberal
democrats have been running cities in
this country for decades poorly
why is it so bad right now they've run
them poorly it was always bad but now
it's gotten
totally out of control and it's really
because they wanted to fund the police
and biden wants to fund the funding
sir he does not look he signed a
charter with bernie sanders there's
nothing about the funding
oh really it says abolish it let's go
all right give me the charter please all
right
so that led to a very interesting
exchange where he had his staff go out
and get
the highlights from that hundred page
compact that the biden team
and the trump team uh rather the biden
team and the sanders team had signed
and he went through it uh and he found a
lot of things that he objected to that
biden has agreed to
but he couldn't find any indication
because there isn't any
that joe biden has sought to defund and
abolish the police
just amazing i mean lots of people wish
biden wanted to defund the police or
abolish the police
but he doesn't want to and chris wallace
fact-checking trump in real time there
now in a moment i'm going to get to
chris wallace more more deeply
but for now wallace is at least doing
the the basic fact checking now
you'd think that after that bogus attack
on biden completely backfired
trump wouldn't try another one but he
tries to suggest
biden will end religion in the united
states if joe biden is president
according to trump joe biden will end
religion take a look we'll call religion
will be gone
okay life you could forget about that
the whole question of life
supreme when you say life you mean
abortion absolutely
a hundred percent that whole question
which is a very you know it's always
been a 50-50
thing it's actually trending a little
bit more toward
once religion is going to be gone what
does that mean look at what they're
doing to the churches
they won't let the churches even open if
they want to stand in a field
six feet apart now i've said before i
don't care if a president is religious
i just want religion kept out of
governance that's secularism secular
secularism isn't people can't be
religious it's
in their role as as a public servant
religion should play
no role in that governance but the facts
happen to be joe biden's more religious
than donald trump i mean
it's not a preference i don't care about
presidential religiosity
but we know trump is not religious and
only pretends to be religious in order
to appeal to evangelical voters
trump might even be an atheist i have a
segment about this that i did a couple
years ago
joe biden is a religious guy and
obviously religion will not be gone
under joe biden
just bungled bizarre claim after claim
here by donald trump
at another point in the interview trump
refers to world war one and world war
ii as beautiful wars apropos of nothing
i mean this was
sort of like related to confederate
statues and monuments and he throws in
that that the wars were beautiful
and he also says what are you going to
name stuff after all al sharpton or
something
the national defense authorization act
the ndaa
you have threatened to veto it because
in the bill
and this is supported by republicans as
well as democrats it would rename
army bases named for confederate
generals now this is a bill that funds
military operations it gives soldiers a
pay raise
you're going to veto that because
they'll get their pay raise hey look
don't tell me this
i got soldiers the biggest pay raises in
the history of our understood
of our military i got soldiers brand new
equipment brand new jets brand new
rockets brand new 2.5 trillion i did
more for the military
than any president that's ever had this
is going to be
because i think that fort bragg fought
robert and lee all of these forts that
have been named that way for
a long time decades and decades the
military says therefore
excuse me i don't care what the military
says i do
i'm supposed to make the decision fort
bragg is a big deal
we won two world wars nobody even knows
general break
we won two world wars go to that
community where fort bragg is in a great
state
i love that state go to go to the
community say
how do you like the idea of renaming
fort bragg
and then what are we going to name it
you're going to name it after the
reverend al sharpton
what are you gonna name it chris tell me
what you're gonna name it this
is the interview version of uh sort of a
rorschach test it's like an ink blot
what do you see here it's complete free
association
and in terms of november chris wallace
gives donald trump the results of a new
fox news poll in which biden is plus
eight we're going to look at that poll
in detail later and trump just says oh
it's all fake polling
mr president you'll be happy to know
that fox news has a new poll out today
and you're going to be the very first
person to hear about it
in the national horse race joe biden
leads you by eight points
49 to 41 that's i think three four
points slimmer
than it was a month ago and on the
issues
people trust biden more to handle the
coronavirus by 17 points on race
relations by 21 points
and even on the economy they trust biden
moore by one point i understand we still
have more than 100 days to this election
but at this point
you're losing first of all i'm not
losing
because those are fake polls they were
fake in 2016
and now they're even more fake the polls
were much worse in 2016.
they interviewed 22 percent republican
well how do you do 22
republican you see what's going on uh i
have other polls that put me
leading and we have polls where i'm
leading i have a poll where we're
leading in every swing state
maybe i don't understand the trumpist
mentality
but it seems to me trump could be
prepared to answer these questions about
polls in a more reasonable way like if i
were trump and of course
i'm not trump if i was dealing with
being down by double digits in most
polls and i'm confronted about it i
don't say the polls are fake i would say
listen chris there's a reality right now
the country's in a tough place because
of coronavirus
and as president the buck stops with me
this is me pretending
to be trump but but reasonable i
understand
the frustration i hear the frustration
my promise to you and to the american
people is
that between now and election day i will
do everything in my power to singularly
focus on
the virus because dealing with the virus
will help the economy it will help
education it will help everything what
matters is polling in november
and i am going to leave no doubt in
every american's mind
that between now and november 3rd they
will see that i am pouring my life
into resolving this situation and in the
end they will see that i've earned a
second term
like wouldn't that be more powerful than
the polls are fake and i'm really
winning
you can't trust the fake news media on
the same topic
trump asked was asked whether he would
accept the results of the upcoming
election
trump of course is losing in every poll
but things can change between now and
november
and trump is unwilling to say i will
accept the results
and he says mail in voting could
actually rig the election
you don't know until you see it depends
i think mail-in
voting is is going to rig the election i
really do uh
are you suggesting that you might not
accept the results of the election i
have to say
look hillary clinton asked me the same
thing no i asked you the same thing in
the debate
there is a tradition in this country in
fact one of the prize of this country is
the peaceful transition of power and
that no matter how hard fought a
campaign is
that at the end of the campaign that the
loser concedes to the winner not saying
that you're necessarily going to be the
loser or the winner but that the loser
concedes to the winner
and that the country comes together in
part for the good of the country
are you saying you're not prepared now
what i'm saying is that i will tell you
at the time
i'll keep you in suspense well chris and
you know what
she's the one that never accepted it
great she never accepted her loss and
she looks like can you give
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election i have to see
look you i have to see no i'm not going
to just say yes i'm not going to say no
and i didn't last time either remember
that trump doesn't realize
that when we talk about vote by mail
this year
all we're talking about is expanding
absentee ballots for anybody
if they want an absentee ballot they can
they can request one and get one
but trump seems to not understand that
and continues to
refuse to say i will accept the election
results
then we get into coronavirus stuff trump
wrongly claims
that we have one of the lowest mortality
rates in the world that's not true
as i've shown you before our deaths per
capita are the 10th highest in the world
chris wallace calls trump on it and the
white house tried giving chris a
completely bogus chart
you're going to have to take a look at
this more closely and we will talk about
it after this when the did the european
union
very early but when you talk about
mortality rates i think it's the
opposite i think we have one of the
lowest
mortality rates we had 900
deaths in a single day we will take away
this week ready
do you contribute can you please get me
the mortality right yeah kaylee's right
here
i heard we have one of the lowest maybe
the lowest mortality rate anywhere in
the world you have the numbers please
because i heard we had the best
mortality
simulated rate as uh dr burks points out
and this is number number one little
mortality right
i hope you show the scenario because it
shows what fake news is all about okay
okay i don't think i'm fake news but
i will we'll put it on we'll put our
stats you said we had the worst
mortality rate in the world
and we have the best all right it's a
little complicated but
bear with us we went with numbers from
johns hopkins university which charted
the mortality rate for 20 countries hit
by the virus
the u.s ranked seventh better than the
united kingdom
but worse than brazil and russia the
white house went with this chart from
the european cdc
which shows italy and spain doing worse
but countries like brazil and south
korea doing better
so what's interesting about this is do
you believe
trump really is being told we have the
lowest mortality rate like this is a
very instructive clip
because our deaths per capita are the
10th highest in the world
what the white house gave fox is a chart
of case fatality rates which is death
relative to testing which is not
informative here but what's extra wild
about this is
trump has admitted he wanted to slow
down testing to keep case numbers
low the case fatality rate goes up
if you keep case numbers low so trump's
admitted strategy of trying to slow
testing actually increases the case
fatality rate which
isn't even the right measure so this is
like
incompetence plus ignorance plus
self-inflicted damage
and we're going to compare these metrics
in an upcoming segment because i want to
make sure
that everybody sort of understands all
of the different
components to this now in this next clip
here is
dripping sweaty trump asked about mask
wearing
and he says well you know masks cause
problems too
so definitely no national mask mandate
who
wore a mass for the first time in public
at walter reed
this weekend question the cdc says if
everybody wore
a mask for four to six weeks we could
get this under control
do you regret not wearing a mask in
public from the start
and would you consider will you consider
a national mandate that people need to
wear masks no i want people to have a
certain freedom
and i don't believe in that no and i
don't agree with the statement that if
everybody wear a mask everything
disappears hey dr fauci said don't wear
a mask
our surgeon general terrific guy said
don't wear a mask
everybody was saying don't wear a mask
all of a sudden everybody's got to wear
a mess
and as you know masks cause problems too
with that being said
i'm a believer in masks i think masks
are good
bottom line is the president said he is
not going to issue a national mandate on
mass he's going to leave it up to the
individual governors
in their states now what's funny here is
trump lists
only reasons not to wear a mask but says
he still supports them
like if he really believed you know
fauci said don't wear one
even though that's been explained adam
said don't wear one the surgeon general
even though that's been explained
and masks cause problems but i'm still
in favor of them
that's weird in its own way like why
would you be in favor of something
about which you can only name negatives
and and
anti-endorsements it doesn't really make
sense and then we get to
sort of this this kind of bombshell
except it's sort of hard to even believe
chris wallace brings up since
coronavirus hit
some people have lost health insurance
people have lost jobs
and their health insurance is tied to
the job so they lost health insurance
and he mentions fortunately we have the
affordable care act obamacare and people
are signing up for it
but you want to get rid of it why are
you doing this now and
trump claims that in two weeks there
will be a completely
brand new health care system to replace
obamacare
what yes take a listen in history
i want to talk to you about obamacare
since the pandemic hit
millions of people have lost their jobs
and thereby lost their health insurance
and almost a half a million have signed
up for obamacare
your administration just announced that
you're signing on to a lawsuit
to overturn obamacare and replace it
why does it make sense to overturn
obamacare with which people now are
relying on democrats are going to say
the man who's wanted to kill obamacare
is going to take away your the
protection for pre-existing conditions
first of all we got rid of the
individual mandate
pre-existing conditions will always be
taken care of by me and republicans a
hundred percent but you've been in the
office three and a half years you don't
have to
we haven't had uh excuse me you heard me
yesterday
we're signing a health care plan within
two weeks
a full and complete health care plan
that the supreme court decision on daca
gave me the right to do so we're gonna
solve we're gonna sign an immigration
plan
now this interview was filmed a few days
ago so
it's not two weeks from yesterday
according to when trump said this
he says we are 10 days from a
completely new health care plan what's
the plan
we don't know some republicans must know
about it right somebody must know about
if we're 10 days from a replacement to
obamacare somebody must know about it
we've heard nothing about that at all
from anybody that's been asked
and then here in closing trump attacks
fox news on fox news
this was the start of the interview in
fact which has sort of become a constant
side story trump going after fox news
but chris wallace basically asks if
trump understands journalism
some people were surprised when you
agreed to this interview to sit down
with me
what are you going to ask especially
because of some of the mean tweets
that you've said about me mike wallace
wanna be nasty and obnoxious
i will tell you after that one my son
peter who you've met called and he said
nasty no obnoxious maybe
but here's the question one of your beef
seems to be
that i put democrats on the show and i
ask them questions
and i guess the question i have is don't
you understand it's my job
to put democrats on as well as
republicans and to ask them probing
questions just like i ask republicans
i'm not a big fan of fox i'll be honest
with you they've changed a lot since
roger ailes
and i watch people like swalwell who i
don't even know he goes on the show
he got less than one percent so trump
just doesn't get
how journalism works and in fact there's
very little journalism
even happening on fox but the little of
it that is happening
trump hates so i mean what do we make of
this this really is like nothing that
we've ever seen
and my takeaway is anyone supporting
this
is no friend of ours it just can't be
like this has to stop even if you like
low
taxes or something and you consider
yourself like a mitt romney fiscal
conservative
you can't support this you you really
can't and this is
um uh we we have to be getting to the
end
one quick note about chris wallace chris
wallace has been praised as wow fox news
host obliterate
host obliterates trump and what a great
job he did chris wallace is no great
hero
okay chris wallace is playing softball
when everyone else is playing t-ball so
it looks like he's playing hard
hardball right in other countries a
president
this incompetent wouldn't be able to do
a single interview
because they would all go far worse than
this it would be impossible for
presidents in other countries
based on how media will actually
question presidents remember
trump said during this interview hillary
didn't accept the election results in
2016. what are you talking about
she immediately conceded and we barely
heard from her for a year or longer
um trump said biden would turn us into
venezuela
and and chris wallace said nothing now i
understand
you can't i've experienced this you
can't turn every misstatement into a
fight
but the idea that this is some hardball
interview
from chris wallace this is like a five
out of ten
and it looks intense because just about
every other interview is a one out of
ten or two out of ten when trump goes on
fox and friends
when trump goes on hannity etc so let's
not give chris wallace more
praise than he deserves although let's
be clear that in in the fox universe
this isn't too common
but remember this plays into fox's
strategy of saying
we have a diversity of views on our
program we have chris wallace
who asks obvious journalistic questions
and then we have everything else who who
you know people just gushing
about donald trump don't fall for the
gushing praise
of chris wallace let me know your
reaction to this
i'm on twitter at dpakman privacy.com is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you five dollars just for using their
free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn
from your checking account but your real
card number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to
the company and i know i won't be
charged in the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman